[Musica]
pensate ad un'opera d'arte
anche di leonardo da vinci
per esempio il disegno della testa dorso
che è stato battuto all'asta da
christie's un mese fa per più di 10
milioni di dollari
ecco adesso pensate ad un'opera d'arte
digitale e pensate a 69 milioni di
dollari
l'undici giugno 2000 21 christie sbatte
all'asta un'opera d'arte digitale
dell'artista b pole per 69 milioni di
dollari
quest'opera digitale è un mft non fangi
ball token
una certificazione
di autenticazione
attraverso cui gli asset digitali come
per esempio anche le opere d'arte
digitali vengono appunto certificati e
validati e vendute sul blog chain
altrimenti per loro natura questi asset
digitali sarebbero spendibili
riproducibili quindi non avrebbero
valore e la bluocean non è altro che un
libro mastro un registro di transazioni
condivise immutabili e validate da un
consenso
distribuito
per me un anno effetti non era altro che
il motivo per cui anni fa tutti mi
presero per pazzo
addirittura accusandomi di essermi
trasferito a new york per occuparmi di
ra nette digitali
ecco questo talk oggi non è una
rivincita ma è per me l'occasione di
spiegarvi finalmente non cosa sia un mft
ma cosa vi sia dietro la storia
meravigliosa della cripta arte e della
sua community
e questa è la storia di come io abbia
avuto l'opportunità di trovarmi nel
momento giusto al posto giusto
tra i pionieri della cripto arte è la
storia che precede l'asta di b paul di
christie's
quindi prima del marzo del 2021 è la
storia del anno che io che a marzo di
questa era prima di marzo 2021 che io
chiamo anche annozero e che divide il
tempo in avanti christie's e dopo
christie's ecco questa è la storia
dell'era avanti christie's e di questo
spazio che appunto pochi sanno essere
nato molto tempo fa e troppo spesso
associato alla speculazione o
addirittura identificato per sineddoche
appunto tramite i token che sarebbe un
po come parlare l'impressionismo
soffermandosi sulle certifica dei quadri
il mio coinvolgimento con il mondo
dell'arte risale ad anni fa con la mia
scelta di studiare cinese ed arte
contemporanea cinese e buon che pink è
uno scultore cinese che era oggetto
della mia tesi nonché migliore amico e
dell'artista dissidente più famoso del
mondo
letteralmente mi spedì in quel che era
l'avventura più grande della mia vita
sei anni in cina di cui 4 lavorando per
ai wei wei
e ma nel 2018 io ho deciso di
trasferirmi a new york e quindi lascio
quella che era la mia seconda casa tra
l'altro ero partita appunto con un
biglietto di sola andata o anche pd
aveva detto questa è una lettera per te
presente di persona lo studio di ai wei
wei suona alla porta e vedi come va e
così io non ero partita più ma appunto
non ero tornata più scusate ma appunto
nel 2018 e mi ero trasferita a new york
e qui iniziavo la mia seconda grande
avventura della vita che era quella del
mio viaggio nel mondo dell'arte
tecnologia quindi a new york studio la
blog chen la sua applicazione al mondo
dell'arte
lo studio di auto e mi aveva catapultato
a velocità supersonica nel mondo
dell'arte contemporanea
ma per me occuparmene fuori dal contesto
cinese era totalmente diverso io
comunque odiavo le gallerie così come
usiamo i musei e tutto il sistema
arrugginito del mondo dell'arte quindi
stavo cercando delle risposte che
sarebbero arrivate proprio nell'unico
posto al mondo in grado di darle
parliamo del 14 settembre 2018 quando io
ero atterrata a new york da appena due
settimane il mio coinquilino di allora
mi invita ad una conferenza su questa
critto arte arte bruxelles dove al
national art club di manhattan nel giro
di un'ora tutte le certezze ai pilastri
della società si sgretolano senza via di
ritorno
glock chain annulla ogni intermediario
non ci sono più banche non ci sono più
gallerie uno choc era già troppo tardi
per tornare indietro dopo la conferenza
alla cena con gli speaker della
conferenza vicino a me era seduto un
ragazzo teneva in mano questo fumetto di
un ara netta appunto ancora oggi ogni
giorno mi sveglio e credo e penso come
sia possibile che una rana possa
cambiarti la vita
questa la netta di nome pepe è il primo
progetto mai esistito decreto art e
quindi di arte sull'uccello quantomeno
come la intendiamo noi oggi era successo
che qualcuno aveva deciso di riprodurre
in digitale e quello che era il
personaggio del fumetto cartaceo
dell'artista matt fury e qualcun altro
aveva deciso di comprare questa figurina
digitale con moneta digitale quindi era
avvenuta la transazione e quindi si era
raggiunto il consenso che un po
collocare avvenuto anni prima con il
bitcoin che cos'è il valore che cos'è il
consenso nel 2010 un signore telefona
alla catena di pizze americana papa
john's ordina due pizze e propone di
pagare con 10mila bitcoin il ristoratore
accetta quindi da questo momento 10.000
bitcoin anno e valore di due pizze io
timidamente propongo di raccogliere e
parlare di questo progetto su un libro
così proprio da svegliare il mondo
dell'arte e far vedere a tutti quello
che attualmente è lo spazio creativo e
artistico più spontaneo è più puro e
così inizia il mio viaggio nel mondo
della cripta arte come curatrice io mi
butto a capofitto della block chain vado
a tutte le conferenze
amy facciamo riunioni ed enti queste
discussioni infinite con queste comitive
di nerd che mettono in discussione ogni
certezza un toccasana per l'anima e per
il cuore quindi vi coinvolgono la
comunità creativa di new york e mi
intrufolo dappertutto aiuto gli artisti
a
preparare i loro stand faccio la
volontaria così che ho accesso a tutti
gli eventi mondiali più grandi su blob
chain
ma che cos'è nello specifico
questo movimento artistico della cripta
arte se pensiamo che se è vero che
l'arte parla il linguaggio del proprio
tempo
allo stesso modo in cui tempo fa
l'essere umano utilizzava il pennello o
lo scalpello per esprimere la propria
forza creativa
così in questo momento utilizza per
farlo i mezzi tecnologici
io a new york incontro queste due donne
meravigliose judy ebbe a che sono le
fondatrici di dada una piattaforma di
arte digitale dove gli artisti dialogano
e si rispondono a suon di disegni
digitali
loro parlano di arte collaborativa dove
tutti i creatori hanno accesso agli
stessi strumenti come brush tavolozza di
colori e dove le conversazioni finali
visive sotto forma di file digitale
appunto sono autenticate e vendute
tramite blog chain
quindi la critto arte è un movimento
totalmente globale perché grazie ad
internet gli artisti partecipano da
tutto il mondo
e pensate anche ad un movimento che
appunto nasce tra le comunità del web
quindi i creatori hanno addirittura la
possibilità di rimanere anonimi e sono
giudicati solo e solamente per la loro
arte non per la loro formazione e
provenienza sociale età sesso eccetera e
soprattutto dove questi giudici non sono
una manciata di esperti selezionati da
gerrard chi e varie
inoltre la cripta arte è economicamente
sostenibile infatti per la prima volta
nella storia gli artisti sono remunerati
anche dalle vendite sul mercato
secondario
ogni volta che un'opera d'arte passa
nelle mani di altri collezionisti il 10
per cento andrà nelle mani del creatore
del suo creatore del creatore e quindi è
proprio la pop art del nostro tempo è la
critto arte questo movimento artistico
trasparente condiviso partecipativo e
decentralizzato è distribuito pensate
anche ad un linguaggio
ultracontemporaneo ovviamente proprio
per i mezzi che si utilizzano per creare
questa arte e dove la
multidisciplinarità viene spinta all
ennesima potenza
pensiamo al duo artistico italiano a
casa o anche loro pionieri di questo
mondo e per me compagni di viaggio
imprescindibili se pensiamo alle loro
tele in acrilico che se inquadrate e poi
avete dentro le vostre borse abbiamo
messo dei flyer che potete inquadrare
con una app
se pensate appunto a queste tele che
vengono inquadrate attraverso l'utilizzo
di un'ape siani umano digitalmente sui
nostri schermi
oppure tramite la realtà aumentata
oppure se pensiamo alla possibilità mai
esistita prima di riportare in vita
attraverso il digitale la testa a dorso
di leonardo da vinci o addirittura la
possibilità e l'emozione di collaborare
con una
band punk rock come quella di blondie
quindi possibilità mai esistite prima di
questo spazio artistico ecco per la
presentazione del libro di pepe di cui
vi parlavo questa raccolta di 1.774
carte digitali
avevamo organizzato un evento a brooklyn
quindi quello fu il mio primo contatto
vero con la con violetta della critto
arte più pura e non mi dimenticherò mai
anzi ricorderò sempre con molto affetto
la loro prima diffidenza nei miei
confronti tipo lei viene dal mondo
dell'arte e poi alla fine finita
ovviamente con molti brindisi quella
sera mi viene anche raccontata una di
quelle storie che sai che cambieranno il
mondo
il 17 gennaio
2018 a new york era stato organizzato il
primo rer art festival c'erano da da
appunto c'era né cripto punk la
community di pepe rear l'ubs e pochi
altri
questi sapevano che stavano veramente
cambiando il corso della storia ma era
ancora troppo presto soprattutto non si
conoscevano fra di loro e addirittura
non potevano pensare che qualcun altro
nel mondo potesse utilizzare la
bruxelles e per fare arte però pensate
oggi ai cripto punk questi famosissimi
10.000 volti pixelati che hanno
veramente cambiato il corso degli anni
della storia degli anni f.to pensate
anche alla carta di homer perche appunto
lara netta con il volto di homer simpson
che fu battuta all'asta nel 2018 per
40.000 dollari al tempo una cifra
impensabile e che oggi è stata abbattuta
quest'anno è stata battuta per più di
300.000
nel 2019 e vi hanno organizzato il ii re
art festival sempre a brooklyn in
maniera decentralizzata dalla community
e io ne faccio parte con un ragazzo
della community organizziamo questa asta
curata di cripto arte ma super
divertente lui trova tutte queste
queste diverse modalità di fare delle
aste questo tutto per sdoganare ciò a
cui avevamo assistito di persona pochi
giorni prima che era questa asta di
christie's a new york da noi
all'asta si partiva da cifre
stratosferiche si scendeva piano piano e
quando il collezionista diceva stop
comprava l'opera al prezzo raggiunto
quindi immaginatevi l'attenzione il
silenzio oppure si procedeva attraverso
una bond il core molte risate
comunque il mio tempo è scaduto anche se
ci sarebbe molto altro da dire ma quello
che mi preme
è che spero che da oggi in poi quando vi
parleranno degli anni affetti quando vi
parleranno di queste aste da capogiro
con cifre stratosferiche voi non vi
fermerete alla prima informazione e non
solo che cosa è appunto un mft ma la
critto arte è il movimento artistico è
la rivoluzione artistica del nostro
secolo è la possibilità della libertà
d'espressione e anche per ogni creatore
di esprimersi appunto liberamente dare
alla possibilità a tutti di essere dei
creatori
ecco adesso prendiamo tutte queste
informazioni e pensiamo ad una retta a
quella netta di cui vi parlavo una rana
che ha dato la possibilità a centinaia
di creatori di esprimersi liberamente e
alle loro creazioni di essere accettate
senza giudizi le regole
una roma che non ha cambiato solo la mia
vita ma cambiate il mondo una rana che
si è manifestata a noi il
1774 modi diversi come meme più
divertenti come baschi ha come monna
lisa come arte moderna la rana che ha
cambiato il modo di fare arte la rana
per cui io sono qui oggi a parlarvi e
quindi si sono proprio contento di
essermi trasferita per una rana
[Applauso]